back when I play Dharma one of my
favorite mods was wasteland it was a
mode that had a lot more structure than
Daisy it had factions and missions you
still had to scavenge to survive and
people were still the most dangerous
thing out there even though I've played
zombie games like Daisy 7 days to die
and now h1z1 it's hard to shake the
feeling that these games are just a
prolonged death match I'd rather just
get right to it and skip the rubbing
sticks together for an hour while
drinking berry juice battle royale in
h1z1 does just that when you aren't
sitting in a 40-minute q that is I
literally did laundry and watched an
episode of Star Wars rebels before one
of my matches loaded over the weekend
but once you hear drop in you'll see
that battle royale is really the best
thing h1z1 has the offer for shooter
fans that are looking for a much slower
more methodical frankly more ARMA
experience let's talk about the phases
of battle royale phase one is all about
the Hunger Games tactics you can go
middle for all the guns and ammo you
desire but middle is a bloodbath it's
permadeath so getting say shotgun blast
it in the back on landing means another
episode of your favorite TV show before
you can try again this is an alpha build
that means ideally though you'll want to
hit an LZ outside of town phase to get
the guns and the backpack forget that
crappy shotgun most your fights will
happen at range once you have a backpack
a rifle and plenty of ammo don't bother
fighting other players let the bodies
pile up on their own there's no reason
to risk it this early phase 3 navigate
once the gas starts constricting the
game's boundaries which happens in
regular phases pull up your map and
guess what grid square this thing is
going to end in your current grid
squares in the lower right corner if
it's going to end in a city you may want
to get there first pull up and kill
players as they trickle in if it's going
to end in a field you probably want to
get there late and hope there's only a
few survivors left for you to finish off
either way you're gonna have to get
there and it might be a long hike so if
you find a working car that's ideal but
I'd recommend driving through the
wilderness rather
on roads where you'll be a much harder
target and then there's phase 4 kill
everyone you're the last one standing
yeah I can say about that is good luck
what I love about battle royale mode is
that it's very tactical and drawn out
it's one of those modes that gives you
enough rope to hang yourself with what I
currently don't like about battle royale
pretty much server times rounds either
need to be set in smaller portions of
the map and the gas needs to drop
quicker or dead players should become
zombies there are other concerns like
this mode being locked behind some kind
of pay wall or event ticketing system
when h1z1 actually launches and that
would be a no go for me in the end this
mode really is a copy of wasteland mod
but that doesn't mean you can't have a
lot of fun I mean a developer either has
to do something new or just do it better
than the last guy you dawdle
do your on the over you ran me over